Speaker 1: There's a very interesting segment
from MSNBC that I want to look at. Whether
you were a Republican strategist, went on
and said Trump's influence. Trump's power
in the Republican Party is rapidly diminishing,
as evidenced by his smaller and smaller rally
crowds. So you thought I was going to say some
Trump smaller and smaller something else? No, I'm
talking about his rally crowds. Of course, this is
a really interesting segment, and there's actually
a very interesting political question here. Donald
Trump has long equated crowd size with success,
even bragging about the size of the Jan. six
riot mob. Republican strategist Susan del %HO
said Trump is now falling short by that measure
as his rally crowds decrease in size. Now one
important thing is, you might say, but David
Trump hasn't conceded that his rally crowds are
diminishing in size. I know we covered a recent
Trump rally, and Trump said there were 87000
people in the audience. There were five to
7000 people in the audience. Trump recently
did an event where you can publicly look
up the capacity of the venue. It was 5500,
and Trump said there were tens of thousands of
people there. Trump's not telling you the truth
about the crowd size, but there is a good
question here, given that the crowds have
been diminishing. Is that actually evidence that
Trump's influence in the party is diminishing?
Let's listen to Susan del Patricio on MSNBC's I
Speaker 3: want to ask you about Congressman
Madison Cawthorn. How do you interpret that warm
welcome he got? Is he the future of the GOP?
Absolutely not. He is the future of Donald Trump
and his shrinking base. And that's what you saw.
There are very shrinking base. I'm not saying
that the Republican Party is going to come
out of Donald Trump in two, four, even six
years. But even this Congressmember is being
shunned by members of his own party. Donald
Trump. Yes, he can bring out those people,
but those crowds are getting smaller and
people aren't buying into it, mostly because
Democrats and Republicans, excuse me, want to move
on. They don't want to talk about the big lie. The
people of this country don't want to hear about
it anymore. They're done with Donald Trump and his
lies. Except for a small group that we see there.
Speaker 1: I don't know that that's true. I don't
know that that's true. It is clear that Trump's
power may be diminishing and the 2022 midterms
are going to be a big factor in helping us
figure that out. It's not really clear to me
that by any significant margin, Trump's power
in the Republican Party is diminishing, and I
think it's really important to remember the 2020
election if you looked at the Democratic primary
before Joe Biden won it. And you just said,
let me pick some ways to determine enthusiasm.
You would have seen that Joe Biden wasn't having
big rally crowds. Now I don't know that he was
trying because of the pandemic and things that
were going on at the time. But if you took a
look at the rally crowds and then you looked on
Reddit and Twitter, you would have said, Oh, wow,
Bernie is going to run away with this thing. Biden
has no chance. And it wasn't reflective of what
was going on with the average Democratic voter
in so many different states around the country.
And people get mad at me when I say this. I'm
not telling you this because it was the way I
would have liked it to be. I'm telling
you this because it was the way it was.
Joe Biden's support was dramatically understated,
and Bernie support was dramatically overstated.
Similarly, Trump had far bigger crowds than
Biden throughout the throughout the campaign.
A lot of it was Biden wasn't trying to do big
events because of the pandemic. But if you go
by rally crowd, I think you're going to end up
confused. There are lots of people who just don't
see politicians as cult leaders, essentially. They
don't really care about going to a rally. I don't
care about political rallies, you know. I'm not
looking to put myself in situations where I've got
a lineup for four hours outside and then use these
fetid sani cans for hours while I'm waiting for.
I'll just watch it at home. I don't need to go.
And so I don't really know that we can make too
much of the rally crowds. A few things we can look
at our polls. If you look at recent Republican
primary polls from the last couple of months, you
see that in Nevada, Donald Trump is still easily
winning. If these were 2024 polls in Massachusetts
among Republicans, Donald Trump is easily winning.
In Minnesota, Trump is winning. Actually, no, I'm
sorry. In Minnesota, Trump is not winning. But in
most states, Trump is either basically tied for
first or easily in first place. So I just don't
think we have the evidence at this point that
Trump's power in the party is diminishing. Again,
looking at the predicted dawg numbers, these are
the betting numbers Trump is still. I don't want
to say running away with it, but thirty nine
cents of every dollar being bet, our Trump will
be the nominee. Twenty nine cents are going to De
Sanders, so that is close, that is close compared
to what it was. But Trump is still in the lead.
My hope is that it's an extraordinarily ugly,
divisive and destructive 2024 primary. But to even
get to that, we've got to get past the midterms
will have all of these stories on our Instagram.
You can find us there at David Pakman show